voici donc le test passé par donald
trump voici à quoi ressemble évaluation
cognitive de montréal mise au point par
le docteur jan nasreddine et qui doit
permettre de poser un diagnostic en 10 à
12 minutes
on demande dessiner leur sur une horloge
de savoir reconnaître un chameau ou de
donner le point commun entre un train et
un vélo aussi on demande de répéter une
liste de mots tels que visage velours
église marguerite rouge et une série de
chiffres par exemple et de se les
remémorer un peu plus tard
aussi on demande d'exécuter une série de
soustraction facile de type sans -7 puis
93 - 7 et ainsi de suite
donald trump a obtenu le score maximum
de 30 sur temps il n'y a absolument
aucun signe d'un quelconque problème
cognitif a conclu le médecin de la
maison blanche jackson toute inquiétude
peut être levé dit-on au delà du score
de 26 surprend le monde peut donc dormir
peut-être un peu plus tranquille
le test a fait ses preuves et son
inventeur est un chercheur et médecin
traitant bien connus et des plus
respectés jade nesrédine est déjà bien
connue des médias traditionnels canadien
pour ses travaux depuis des années sur
cette maladie dégénérative du cerveau
le docteur est aussi le créateur dans un
mur tv lancée sur le web il ya un peu
plus de deux ans afin d'informer les
citoyens du monde entier y aussi de
favoriser la collaboration entre
chercheurs dans le monde
un nouveau test génétique pourrait
bientôt permettre de prédire à quel âge
une personne développera la maladie
d'alzheimer ce test mise au point par
une équipe internationale de
scientifiques analyse l'adn d'un
individu pour ensuite estimer si et à
quel âge où la planète ne sont pas
forcément hors de danger
le médecin de la maison blanche prédit
jackson note dans son rapport que donald
trump ne fait pas un exercice et un demi
kilo environ sous la barre des obèses
surtout que son taux de cholestérol est
extrêmement élevé facteurs qui
pourraient contribuer à l'apparition de
l'alzheimer c'est ce que démontre
maintenant plus récentes recherches
notamment celles effectuées au canada
voient leur risque d'avoir la maladie
d'alzheimer un jour presque doublé le
docteur jude poirier et directeur de
l'unité de neurobiologie moléculaire de
l'institut de sa morial donc biais qu'on
a longtemps à ce cycle latéraux les
maladies cardiaques et c'est toujours
vrai et on survit les maladies
cardiaques
yann deuxième maladie nous attendons des
tours quelques décennies plus tard et
quand on avance beaucoup en âge la
capacité du cerveau à compenser à ceux à
combattre est à toute fin pratique le
processus j'ai cette capacité là elle
s'atténue avec le temps et avec
évidemment les problèmes de cholestérol
y lier ce cholestérol et la capacité de
réparer
un reportage de radio canada
international